let's apply everything we've learned to
an actual differential equation instead
of just taking Laplace transforms and
taking their inverse let's actually
solve a problem so let's say that I had
the second derivative of my function y
plus 4 times my function y is equal to
sine of T sine of T minus the unit step
function 0 up until 2 PI of T times sine
of T minus 2 pi let's solve this
differential equation interpretation of
it and I should do a whole playlist on
interpretations of differential
equations and how do you model it but
you know you can kind of view this as a
forcing function that it's a weird
forcing function of this being applied
to some weight with you know this the
this is the acceleration term right the
second derivative with respect to time
is the acceleration so it'd be that you
know the mass would be 1 whatever units
and then the the just the function just
that's a function of its position this
is probably some type of spring constant
anyway I won't go there I don't to waste
your time with the interpretation of it
but let's solve it we can do more about
interpretations later so we're going to
take the Laplace transform of both sides
of this equation so what's the Laplace
transform of the left-hand side so the
Laplace transform of Y of the second
derivative of Y is just s squared so now
I'm taking the plus transform of just
that Laplace traits with s squared times
the Laplace transform of Y minus lower
the degree there once minus s times y of
0 minus y prime of 0 so clearly I must
have to give you some initial conditions
in order to do this properly and then
plus 4 times the Laplace transform of Y
times the Laplace transform of Y is
equal to is equal to what's the Laplace
transform of sine of T ok that should be
second nature by now it's just 1
over s squared plus one and then we have
- the Laplace transform of this thing
and I'll take a look I'll do a little
side note here to figure out the Laplace
transform of of this thing right here
now we know it I mean I showed it to a
couple of videos ago we showed that the
Laplace transform the Laplace transform
actually I could just I could just write
it out here this is going to be the same
thing as the Laplace transform of sine
of T but if we're have to multiply it by
e to the minus if you remember that last
formula e to the minus CS where C is 2
pi let me actually let me write that
down let me let me I decided to write it
down and then I decided oh no I don't
want to do this but let me write the so
the Laplace transform of the unit step
function that goes up to C times some
function shifted by C is equal to e to
the minus CS times the Laplace transform
of just the original function times the
Laplace transform of F of T right so if
we're taking the Laplace transform of
this thing our C is 2 pi our F of T our
f of T is just sine of T right C is so
then we did this is just going to be
equal to if we just do this piece right
here it's going to be equal to e to the
minus CS our C is 2 pi e to the minus 2
pi s times the Laplace transform of f of
t f of t 2 sine of T right before we
shift it this is f of t minus 2 pi so f
of t is just going to be sine of t so
it's going to be times 1 over s squared
plus 1 this is a Laplace transform of
sine of T so let's go back to our
original back to where we had left off
so we've taken the Laplace transform of
both sides of this equation and clearly
I have some initial conditions here so
the problem must have given me some and
I just forgot to write them down
so let's see the initial conditions I've
I'm givin you there they are written
kind of in the margin here they tell us
I'll do it in orange they tell us that Y
Y of zero is equal to zero and y prime
of zero is equal to zero that makes the
math easy
that's zero and that's zero so let's see
if I can simplify my equation so the
left-hand side let's factor out the
Laplace transform so let's factor out
this term and that term so we get the
Laplace transform of Y times this Plus
this times s squared plus four is equal
to the right hand side and what's the
right hand side it is we get we could
simplify this well I'll just write it
out I don't want to do too many steps at
once it's 1 over s squared plus 1 and
then plus or minus actually this is a
minus minus the Laplace transform of
this thing which was e to the minus 2 pi
s over s squared plus 1 and so we can
write this whole thing as so if we
divide both sides of this equation by
the s squared plus 4 then we get the
Laplace transform of Y is equal to is
equal to and actually I can just merge
these two they have the same denominator
so before I even divide by s squared
plus 4 that right hand side will look
like this
it will look like with a denominator of
s squared plus 1 and you have a
numerator of 1 1 minus e to the minus 2
pi s and of course we're dividing both
sides of equation by s squared plus 4 so
we're going to have to stick that s
squared plus 4 over here now we're at
the hard part in order to figure out why
we have to take the inverse Laplace
transform of this thing so how do we
take the inverse Laplace transform of
this thing
where the hard part is always you know
kind of solving the differential
equations easy if you know the Laplace
transforms so we're going to do is some
it looks like we're gonna have to do
some partial fraction expansion so let's
see if we can do that so we can rewrite
this equation right here we can rewrite
this equation so let's write it as this
because this will kind of simplify our
work let's factor this whole thing out
so we're going to write it as one minus
e to the minus 2 pi s all of that times
do it in orange all of that times 1 over
s squared plus 1 times s squared plus 4
now we need to do some partial fraction
expansion to simplify this thing right
here so we're going to say we're going
to do this on the side maybe I should do
this over on the right right here this
thing let me rewrite it 1 over s squared
plus 1 times s squared plus 4 should be
able to be re-written as 2 separate
fractions s squared plus 1 and s squared
plus 4
with the numerators this one would be a
s plus B it's going to have to have
degree one because this is degree two
here and then we'd have C S Plus D and
so when you add these two things up you
get a s plus B times s squared plus 4 s
squared plus 4 plus C s CS plus D times
s squared plus 1 all of that over the
common denominator right we've seen this
this story before we just have to do
some algebra here as you can tell these
differential equations problems they
require a lot of stamina you kind of
just have to say I will keep moving
forward and do the algebra that I need
to do in order to get the answer and you
kind of have to get excited about that
notion that you have all of this algebra
to do so let's figure it out so this top
can be
simplified to a s to the third a s to
the third plus let's let's say plus B s
squared plus B s squared plus 4 a s plus
4 a s plus 4 B plus 4 B and then this
one is you end up with C s the third C s
to the third plus D s squared plus D s
squared plus CS plus C S Plus D so when
you add all of these up together you get
and this is all the algebra that we have
to do one for better for worse a plus C
over s to the 3rd plus B plus D times s
squared plus 4a plus C times s let's go
over a little bit plus 4 B plus D and
now we just have to say okay so do we
see any all of this is equal to this
thing up here this is the numerator we
just simplified the numerator this is
the numerator that's the numerator right
there and all of this is going to be
over your original s squared plus 1
times your s squared plus 4 and we
established that this thing should be
let me rewrite this that 1 over s
squared plus 1 times s squared plus 4
should equal this thing and then you
just pattern match on the coefficients
this is all this is all just intense
partial fraction expansion and you say
look a plus C is the coefficient of the
S cubed terms I don't see any s cubed
terms here so a plus C a plus C must be
equal to 0
and then you see okay B plus D is the
coefficient on the x squared terms don't
see any s squared terms there so be B
plus D must be equal to 0 for a plus C
coefficient on the S terms don't see any
S terms over here so for a plus C must
be equal to 0 and then we're almost done
for B plus D must be the constant
there is a constant term there so for B
plus D is equal to one so let's see if
we can do anything here if we subtract
this from that we get minus 3a is equal
to zero or a is equal to zero if a is
equal to 0 then C is equal to zero and
let's see what we can get here if we
subtract this from that we get minus 3b
the DS cancel out is equal to minus 1 or
B is equal to 1/3 and then of course we
have D is equal to minus B all right if
we subtract B from both sides so D is
equal to 1/3 so all of that work and we
actually have a pretty simple result we
have a pretty simple result our our
equation this thing here can be
rewritten as this thing can be
re-written as the a disappeared you just
had you know it's 1/3 over s squared
plus 1 B was the coefficient on the we
make it very clear B was a coefficient
on the or it was a term on top of the s
squared plus 1 so that's why I'm using
be there and then D D or D is minus B so
D is minus 1/3 let me make sure I that B
is 1/3 right - let me make sure I get
that right right D is 1/3 so sorry B is
in boy is 1/3 so D is minus 1/3 so B is
a is the term on top of the s squared
plus 1 and then you have minus D over
the minus 1/3 over s squared plus 4 plus
4 this takes a lot of stamina to record
this video I hope you appreciate it
all right ok so let me rewrite
everything just so we can get back to
the problem because when you take that
partial fraction detour it kind of you
forget yeah I mean not not even to speak
of the problem you forget what day it is
let's see so you get the Laplace
transform of Y is equal to 1 minus e to
the minus 2 pi s
times what that mess that we just solved
for x and i'll write like this 1/3 times
1 over s squared plus 1 minus 1/3 times
actually let me write it this way
because I have this s squared plus 4 so
I really want to have a 2 there right so
I want to have a 2 in the numerator so
you want to have a 2 over s squared plus
4 so if I if I put a 2 in the numerator
that I have to divide this by 2 as well
so times so let me change this to a 6
right minus 1/6 times 2 is minus 1/3 so
I did that just so I get this in the
form of the Laplace transform of sine of
T now let's see let's see if there's
anything that I can do from here
anything this is this is an epic problem
I'll be amazed if I don't make a
careless mistake while I do this so we
can rewrite everything let's see let's
see if we can simplify this and by
simplifying it I'm just going to make it
longer we can write the Laplace
transform of Y is equal to I'm just
going to multiply the 1 out and then I'm
going to multiply the e to the minus 2
pi s out so if you multiply the 1 out
you get 1/3 times 1 over s squared plus
1 I'm just multiplying the 1 out minus
1/6 these are all the ones times the 1
times 2 over s squared plus 4 and I'm
going to multiply the minus e so this
and then you get my limits which colors
do the minus e so then you get minus e
to the minus 2 pi s PI over 3 times 1
over s squared plus 1 and then the minus
and the minus cancel out so you get plus
e to the minus 2 pi s over 6 times 2
over s squared plus 4 now taking the
inverse Laplace transform of these
things are pretty straightforward so
let's do that let's take the inverse
Laplace transform of the whole thing
and we get y is equal to inverse Laplace
transform of this guy right here is just
1/3 sine of T 1/3 not to write a
parenthesis there sine of T and then
this is minus 1/6 minus 1/6 times this
is the Laplace transform of sine of 2t
sine of 2t that's that term right there
now these are almost the same but we
have this little pesky character over
here we have this e to the minus 2 pi s
and there we just have to remind
ourselves I'll write it here in the
bottom we just have to remind ourselves
that the Laplace transform Laplace
transform of the unit step function I'll
put the PI there just you know 2 pi
times f of t minus 2 pi I should put it
into the step function of T is equal to
e to the minus 2 pi s times the Laplace
transform of just or let me just write
it this way times the Laplace transform
of F of T so if we view f of T is just
sine of T or sine of 2t then we can kind
of backwards pattern match and we'll
have to shift it and multiply it by the
Laplace by the unit step function so I
want to make that clear right if you
just look if you didn't have this guy
here the Laplace inverse Laplace
transform of this guy would be the same
thing as this guy just be sine of T
inverse Laplace transform of this guy
would be sine of 2t but we have this
pesky character here which essentially
instead of having the inverse Laplace
transform just being our f of T it's
going to be our F of T shifted by two pi
times the the unit step function where
it steps up at 2 pi so this is going to
be minus 1/3 minus 1/3 times the unit
step function it goes that where C is 2
pi of T times instead of sine of T sine
of T minus
two pi and then we're almost done almost
done I'll do it in magenta to celebrate
it plus this very last term which is 1/6
times the unit step function to PI of T
you the used step function that steps up
at 2 pi times sine of and we have to be
we have to be careful here instead of
into wherever we had a T before we're
going to replace it with a t minus 2 pi
so sine of a set of 2 t is going to be 2
times t minus 2 pi and there you have it
we finally have solved our our very
hairy problem we could take some time if
we want to simplify this a little bit in
fact we might as well at the risk of
making a careless mistake at the last
moment let me see if I can make any
simplifications here actually it's not
obvious that there's any without kind of
resorting to some type of well we could
factor out this this this this guy right
here but other than that that seems
about as simple as we can get so this is
our function of T that satisfies our
otherwise simple looking differential
equation that we had up here that this
will didn't look this looked fairly
straightforward but we got this big mess
to actually satisfy that equation given
those initial conditions that we had
initially